In today's corporate world,
the importance of diversity,
equity and inclusion in human resources
cannot be understated.
These three principles are
essential for fostering a passative
and inclusive work environment that values and respect
the unique backgrounds and perspective of all employees.
Human resource departments
play a crucial role in driving diversity,
aquity and inclusion initiatives within organizations.
They are responsible for creating
and implementing policies and practices
that promote a diverse workforce,
providing training and development
opportunities to address bias and discrimination
and ensuring that
all employees have assessed opportunities and resources.
Prioritizing diversity,
apathy and collision.
Human resource professionals
contribute to the overall success
and sustainability of organizations.
They help build
strong and in diverse teams that are better
equipped to understand
and cater the needs of diverse customer base.
In conclusion,
they verse the
equity and Galician or integral
to the success of any organization.
Human resource professionals
please a critical role in driving their initiatives
and must continue to champion this values
to create a more equitable
and inclusive environment for all employees.